the heel is what you need to sell the
fight the person with the belt ends up
making the money they're the face Etc
but do they deserve more than the heel
sure if the heel is the one selling the
[__] tickets yeah no I agree with you
whoever gets the lattice reception
there's your answer that's who you start
whoever comes through that you create
that and gets the loudest Roar that's
the star of the show I mean it's not
overly complex I've seen I've seen Dana
White do that math in his head before
bend it away in and not you know who he
thinks the stars are and somebody else
comes through the curtain and the crowd
goes crazy and boom that guy's getting
the bonus I mean I've seen yeah I mean
it's a very simple but it's a pretty
obvious focus group when you have a live
Arena whoever is loudest but I mean it
is it is just one of those things I've
watched guys come from under cars ready
to come in the main event spots just
because of reception that they got at a
press conference like in O'Malley yeah
where the the UFC didn't know they were
stars that wasn't the guy and the
crowd's like let us let you know this is
the go people will decide boom gotcha
they'll move them right up because of
that I've seen other guys that are stars
and undefeated in their High rankings
you know you can't nobody share years
nobody shares when they come through and
you've got to just find a place to stick
them I've been a little critical of the
bullet uh lately and I I do it I really
do do it as a way of trying to help the
bullet I've never met her I think I'm
being helpful to her but the crowd isn't
like the bullet is the people who don't
know which is the problem that you're
talking about she is quite possibly the
the greatest Talent I've ever seen in
unarmed combat she is really fantastic
uh her skills seem to be equal on the
ground as to standing up she can finish
fights anywhere she can deal with
adversity she can push the pace she's
actually weaponized Pace I'm much like
uh Dan Gable did way back in 1972 she is
flat impressive she's also a co-main
event you can't make a dollar with the
girl you can't put her against any
opponent she's fighting this weekend I
don't know who her opponent is and I'm
not attempting to be funny I simply
don't you could give me multiple choice
I wouldn't know but that's her fault you
know I watched her on Ariel yesterday
and she's sitting there you know they
call it crisscross applesauce and she's
telling some stories she's trying to
tell like we're five-year-olds and like
she's the kindergarten teacher it's like
girl strip your clothes off you got
tattoos
supposedly you speak seven languages man
I'm not even sure you've mastered
English which you're speaking to us now
you're not overly uh impressive and
you're a co-main event above everything
else what argument God damn what you
have to say or how many World
Championships you have you can't even
close out the night you got a guy named
surreal gone who's one and one in his
last two and he's walking out after you
there's a Miss there and I don't say
that to put her down she's wildly
successful but why she keeps trying to
pretend that she's a sweet Sally
Homemaker when she's not what should she
be what would you do with her I think in
real life she's a heel I don't know her
I haven't met her personally but I think
she's a heel I've seen her interviews
I've seen her come uh to the aid and to
the defense of some very unsavory
characters and I just thought to myself
you seem like a bad girl when Jon Jones
went down for every steroid in the world
and street drugs and cocaine and he ran
his car and said she was the first to
come and defend it which was very sweet
she has the courage to come out of the
fit it was very sweet but it also isn't
what your kindergarten teacher that
she'd like you to think that she is with
you and I look at her and go you're a
heel just be yourself is there another
reason why she might of course what what
do you think I don't know what do you
think and then you got Holly Hall I mean
you have such a great story if they had
the courage to come and tell them what
is that an interesting thing
I'm not speaking out hypothetically yes
the forces in place there's breakups I
mean all of these things can be Googled
you just have to connect with us and if
you did connect the dots you could make
some money and sell some tickets but
they don't have the courage to connect
the dots they gotta just leave it
lingering while I'm out here on
immediate tour trying to get somebody to
watch a girl and send a comment event
you could make her money right now right
I just said what you were feeling right
now you think that there might be still
at an arena to fight Holly Holm if they
would just tell the story and what's the
story
Holly over you got Valentina here and
you got John over here no I'm not
connected but these are your three what
with the story possibly maybe Jon Jones
was like in an intimate relationship
perhaps with Hollywood make it up yeah
the the bullet shivchenko
came in and stole John Jones from that
if that happened Hollywood fight the
bullet
and Hollywood want to get revenge on the
girl that stole her man and the bullet
who lives over here got assigned to the
March 4th card which Jon Jones's
headline and they're all the same hotel
right now no it looks like the wrong
fight that
I don't know I don't know that's an
incredible tale that you're that'd be
crazy if that happened yeah and um but
imagine that that happened and they came
out and they told the world instead of
hiding behind it imagine the interest
that you could possibly have
one is the world champion who's won more
World Championship the the other's not
you understand we have a world title
fight that is not the main event on a
card we have a non-world title fight
that's headline the card that's a
problem for them yeah for them that's a
problem that could be changed but it
would take courage to tell a story does
it have anything to do with their
genitals I don't know I mean I don't
know I think you're talking about the
the men traditionally do better I mean
we saw UFC was it 200 Misha Tate Amanda
Nunes so we have seen the woman uh go
later before but it is it is a hard fact
of a policy that a championship match
closes out the night there needs to be a
story I agree with you I I don't even
know what the story is
the belt has the headlines well it is
headlining I think Jon Jones and Sarah
gone are gone are fighting for the belt
but neither of one of them is Champion
that's the difference ah you're saying
the champion always has to happen
policy that they have never broken and
she does such a bad job that they have
to break their own policy because they
can't walk her out you want her to say I
stole your man I want her to come out I
want to knock you out yeah I don't want
her to come out and do this pretending
she speaks seven languages I don't want
her to come out and pretend that she's
trained in the military I don't want her
to come out and act she's got a sister
in the business her mother was a world
champion she grew up in a very rough
household and she is an incredible uh
story and an incredible product of a
very difficult upbringing she is not a
kindergarten teacher she is not a nice
girl she has tattoos on her body she
gets in a cage and she tries to hurt
other people that she was trained and
designed to do there's nothing wrong
with telling that story what up
everybody I gotta interrupt this clip
real quick because somebody probably
looking for the full episode you're like
where the hell is it well it's out next
week that's right we got the king of
trash talk okay and he's delivering
absolute Mayhem burning every bridge
known to man it's jail sun and
delivering a barnyard of a podcast
and saying stuff like this oh I used to
rob banks
I thought you knew that oh I used to Rob
bags I thought you knew that how do you
rob a bank that's what got complicated
jail time no no joke no jail ten
thousand dollar fine but they got some
performance since answers like if the
world understood what LeBron did we have
the same drug guy if you will I know
exactly what he's doing isn't Netflix
the bank though isn't it Netflix
single-handedly save comedy
you mentioned 100 million for Floyd the
first time he's never gotten 100 million
for a flight I know it is they're
claiming he was doing 100 million to
find and I'm claiming for you he and his
whole career has made about 100 million
teams island did you enjoy your time
there
that's not a gotcha I'm just genuinely
curious I would have gone
yeah but we ended right there the
American Gangster the bad guy is on
flagrant next week now let's get back to
this question would you consider being
like a consultant for a league because
it feels like you can sell a storyline
in the way like um Eric Bischoff who did
WWE sure I remember Eric and you yeah
Easy E yeah yeah I feel like you can do
a very similar thing I don't I'm sure
you're making a lot of money Now podcast
is 12 times bigger than ours but first
but uh I think you can make a lot of
money doing that I appreciate that and I
just think there's a story and I and I
have to say this Andrew because it's
important to me because I didn't come
here to give the bullet a hard time or
even outer Dirty Laundry like I think
that she's a really interesting gal I
had a dream and I worked really hard and
I fell short I didn't get to as good as
she was or as talented or as many wins
and as many Gold Belts that I've had
during laundry with Holly Holm cleaner
like that would be a really incredible
reason for them to fight it really would
I mean you have two people that just
can't draw flies and I don't say it to
pick on her I say it because there's a
difference if you're going to come out
you're going to do the interview anyway
yeah one you can sit crisscross
applesauce and speak to the audience
like you're a fourth grader or the other
one you can come on to Ariel's show talk
about the world championship the next
girl you're gonna beat up and by the way
I'm gonna stop by this guy's room in the
meantime damn his knees might be weak by
the time he walks in the main event
because it'll be the night before
there's a way to tell a story
and they're true just come out and tell
the story so what makes a better fight
two heels or a heel in a face well
there's there's nothing more monetizable
than a cool heel now a cool heel is hard
to come by a cool heel stone cold yeah
uh the rock uh we're cool heels man if
you throw me in there that was very
sweet of you but Conor would go into
that category too Connor didn't come out
to get she already came out to get booed
but then he kind of looked cool doing it
and you have the bow tie and you had the
accent and you know he got a good little
build on him and almost sudden he wins
World Championships he's headlined
Madison Square Garden I mean some of
that stuff just happens yeah the other
part you can manufacture I I just
suggest if you have a store to tell your
story that that would be my only advice
if you have a story tell your story if
you try to lie to the audience like
chefchenko you're going to end up a
co-man event if you're happy in your
career talk about the time that you've
one fights in a co-med of its spot do it
your way so it's better to have two
heels but if they're cool heels that's
even better I think it's just better to
tell the story the way that it happened
if you got a reason to fight this person
tell what it is if you have no you don't
don't even know who this person is and
Dana White drew the name out of a hat
and you got a phone call one day tell
that if that's really is the story then
go out and tell that because that's also
being a heel yeah I don't know who this
girl is sure Dana White put picked a
name out of a hat I have no [__] clue
who she is but I'm gonna get paid money
to go there and beat her ass yeah and
it's low level that's condescending it's
like the new boyfriend has to act like
he doesn't know the old boyfriend's name
you know he's not James Jackson Colin
John I mean there's some stuff that's
bigger than all of us but yeah yeah I
would just store for you if you're
telling a story and you have a really
good one to tell it tell it I mean I I
just gave you one on shipchenko give
this one give us one more Jon Jones and
serial gun okay what
you gotta understand here's the problem
Jon Jones is like my arch nemesis so I
gotta look at this from a negative
standpoint but I'll come out and tell
the story the way that it is in the top
25 ranked heavyweights there's only one
who's never had a wrestling match his
name is surreal gone there's only one
heavyweight in the top 25 that doesn't
have a black belt in Jiu Jitsu his name
is surreal gone surreal gone is one and
one in his last two he sucks and the
most conversation I've ever had was
the most conversation I've ever had on
this guy in my life is with John annik
where we're arguing over the correct
enunciation of the guy's last name which
seems to be gone yeah yeah yeah now I
don't say that because I have heat with
surreal I want to take away from what
the Glorious moment that John's about to
have I'm an evil person and I want to
get in front of that I will burn surreal
gone just to take away from John now
John meanwhile doesn't have a license in
this weight class set out after failing
more drug test than me which is hard to
do
instead of his ass for three years thumb
up his ass for three years all because
Dominic Reyes should have got to jump on
him and these are the two guys for the
world championship Jon Jones goes from
the youngest champion of all time to the
oldest contender in the company's
history come on do you resent John a
little bit because he's kind of a real
life heel who gets to be kind of a face
yes and you are whoa yeah because I yeah
I knew when I walked in here I resent
him I thought that that was jealousy and
possibly even Envy but I like how you
said it
and you're proud of the fact I don't us
I you love your wife a lot she dresses
that's a hot one did you ever see my
wife Miss Brittany yeah
yeah yeah dude
you are a real life face but when the
cameras are on you go heal and then Jon
Jones is Almost the opposite and he gets
the adulation and I know you say booze
are like cheers for a heel but it's
still got to sting a little bit yes that
you're such a good guy and you don't get
the cheers you get the Boost there's
some truth to that I mean I can't deny
what you just said nobody's ever said it
back to me but that that sounds right
well you spent your whole career trying
to be hated and people just love you
yeah I mean you guys are being a little
overly nice to me I've got to tell you
but uh
hate on you in the beginning you just
wouldn't do it I hold you [__]
Canadians
I thought maybe you're going somewhere
this guy's the ultimate Patriot of
I don't know where we were going with
that but I said I got to hear from Dana
White right I did an interview last
night I got to hear from Dana why are
you bearing my main event it's like well
let me tell you why I'm bearing your
main event it purely comes from Envy it
comes from Envy my envy that I have for
John I tried to fight you I couldn't
beat John John was better than me and
instead of having to admit that I still
got to be a man so I got to come out and
bury him but that's the real truth the
other side of it is the youngest
Champion he's now your oldest Contender
and he's fighting a guy that's one and
one in his last two oh and by the way
chefchenko who's the queen of the sport
is a co-main event I'm not saying that's
not true but there's a way to tell the
truth and make it interesting okay talk
to me oh I feel like I'm doing that now
I feel like I just laid the truth out
for you but I made an interest I feel
like I did that but what is the desire
like I feel like the desire to see Jon
Jones fight has nothing to do with Sarah
gone it's like does he still have it
after three years is he the greatest of
all time can he move up and do it but it
has nothing to do with this fight so
you're you're basically limiting
yourself by 50 of the promotion yeah
there's no interest like I don't need to
see him beat serial gun sure and I don't
I'm not like in love with zero gone
enough to see him beat Jon Jones I don't
even know if they've spoken at all in
the Pro in the promo for this fight sure
have they had like uh back to like uh
I'm gonna face off but like if they you
know on ESPN hopped on talk some [__]
about one that's what I've seen not that
I've seen it's tough the the single
greatest storyline in heavyweight
history was Francis ngono versus surreal
gone finding out that they were
teammates that the coach had to make a
split the manager made a split they
moved away those and it was projected to
1.2 million just to share for you it did
just over 300 000. it was the biggest
flop uh of last year and it was a
stunning thing to one It flopped because
those guys refused to tell a story
neither one of them wanted to me they
were focused and they were telling them
whatever it was we barely sell out the
arena nobody watches on pay-per-view and
then Francis wants to turn the gun on
the on the company and act like I'm
gonna walk away and go fight Tyson
Furious what difference does it make if
you do nobody's tuning in to watch you
fight I don't know if Dana will ever
have a better story for Francis than he
had with surreal I just those don't come
along very often but he's supposed to
turn it into a bigger right I mean of
course you of course you let the guy
walk I mean I think the story with
Francis is just being the most
destructive human being on the planet
and I don't know how much more you need
after that sure you know like even the
early Tyson days it's like this guy's
gonna just devour somebody and I think
that's what we started seeing with
Francis and uh his backstory is cool too
oh his backstory is great and it's sweet
but I hear what you're saying it's like
nobody wants to sweep back somewhere
they want to see the blood boil a little
bit so how do you make the blood boil
yeah and we can say it's sweet and great
we can do those things to be nice it did
300 000 on a projected 1.2 like we don't
have to pretend to be nice because he
sucks as a draw that's the truth well
because he's a face is that why they let
him go
yeah I mean at some point what are you
going to do 1.2 they're gonna cut the
[__] check absolutely cut it for
Connor 100
I mean I'm just sharing for you like we
need to sit back and be nice because we
here here's what your numbers are here
is the opportunity you had with the
single greatest storyline in history and
here's what your numbers were here's
also how many times you went on ESPN
house many times you went on roundhouse
how many times you sat down with Andrew
there's ways to look at what you did to
create that number and he and surreal
took their ball and went home
that's just the truth I don't know why
surreal at one and one is getting put
back in the main event when you can't
count them anyway what are you going to
do surreal becomes your Champion you
already had that problem you're going to
stop selling tickets in the heavyweight
division who would you put there well
that's why they're in a tough spot right
now I would have liked to have seen uh
Stipe I don't think his time's done but
I know that clock's ticking I know he's
he's close to 40. I think he's he's over
it and I know that that clock's ticket
I'd like to see Francis get back in
there that would be my prediction what
happens with Francis next my prediction
is that that he comes back home I think
that Francis versus John is something
really special and other than that I
mean the heavyweight's got some work
today why is that special What's the
storyline Francis being as big as he was
France is barely making the lemon we
don't have a lot of big guys in boxing
either until the klitschkos came along
or now Tyson Fury we've really never had
anybody that was a really big guy size
was always a disadvantage
Lennox was big
man six six something like that for sure
I'm not saying it was massive but I hear
what you're saying was probably 212
pounds or something like that 198 the 91
the heavyweight championship Mike Tyson
you need to talk about a reach advantage
and a size Advantage Mike Tyson never
had the longer arm and he never weighed
more than a single opponent yeah I just
think that's interesting because it's
really not an advantage to have a longer
arm it's really not advantage to weigh
more but we continually call it one so I
only bring that too because it is
something interesting about Francis okay
he's got this destruction okay just on
signs alone we know Science Matters he
hits something he can destroy it all of
those lines then he takes on Jon Jones
who was a a National Collegiate
wrestling champion Jon Jones seems to be
one takedown away from taking everything
from Francis but can he take him down
it's an interesting one piece because
according to John No according to John
himself I'm not big enough according to
John I will not get in there I will not
even try until I get to a certain weight
which took him three years to do and I
think I think just that denial and
refusal to fight Francis until he got
big enough that he was comfortable
fighting Francis makes for a Mystique of
Kenny B Francis and you also have
the pound for pound Great would you call
Francis the pound for pounds
he was the best at heavyweight but no I
don't think he was very uh well okay the
most destructive person on the planet
there you go sure versus the greatest of
all time sure
everybody wants to see that for sure
actually yeah there's good story there
yeah and you can I mean I don't know if
he wants it but you could make Jon Jones
a heel against because there's no more
bigger face than Francis sure because
based on his story so even that failure
with this hero gone fight is somebody
who's I'm admittedly big in the office
of the UFC I would say isn't that on the
heel to carry that fight because this
guy's the face yeah you beat the heel if
you're gone now you gotta [__] now
you're cooking I love what you're saying
I don't I don't disagree with any of
that and Francis is you know you guys
comment that you know historic boy it
that almost brings a tear to your eye
when you hear what he went through to
get here like that that is such a
lovable story and I don't know I don't
know why he didn't Embrace telling that
more I don't I don't know why he let
that go I don't know why he you know I
feel like he shared it Fran for Francis
to fight Tyson Fury is not a draw just
like McGregor to fight Mayweather is not
a draw that's a draw the sitting that's
crazy well I'll tell you this way though
and just disagree with me if I make this
claim though McGregor did not get paid
to fight Mayweather the simultaneous two
division UFC champion with Dan white in
his Corner got paid to fight me I'm with
you on that I think Francis is more
valuable to that Tyson fight if he is
the current heavyweight champion yeah
accordingly Tyson said I will box the
UFC champion well now he's got a guy
that's not the champion yeah yeah and if
you ever want to see that get spoiled
Dana White grabs a microphone one time
and says Tyson if you really want to do
this here's John Jones and I'll let you
fight him Dana says that one time
Francis well in France and no one will
ever say Francis his name again and
that's just the truth yeah but Tyson's
gonna absolutely obliterate John and
John's not gonna do it and Dana's not
gonna do it I I get the play there I'm
just sharing you know this was a this
was a very risk there is value I think
we're undermining the value of the UFC
and France's promotion especially since
he might not be the greatest at
promoting himself outside of the sport
sure
hmm that's interesting so the longer
he's outside of the UFC the more the
stock kind of goes down it would see and
then the less interested Tyson is in the
fight
like I still think Francis has a chance
against Tyson to beat Tyson yeah four
rounds of gloves
okay with the four ounce gloves maybe he
connects but you're talking about I
think
and I'm a boxing fan I think there isn't
a heavyweight in history that could be
Tyson Fury I agree yeah sadly it's crazy
to say it isn't it and it's sad too
because it takes a Nostalgia wave but
Mike I grew up in the Mike Tyson era but
Mike is 5 10. no I gotta be Tyson like I
know and it's one of those things where
it's like it's hard to even formulate
the sentence where you go Tyson fear is
the greatest heavyweight boxer in
history but I think he is yeah but you
just said uh size and reach doesn't make
a doesn't give you an advantage at six
nine yeah six nine versus Five Ten yeah
oh there's yeah there's a Tipping Point
for sure but but that's beautiful what
you're saying I mean if more people
thought that it's also from what I
understand Tyson's footwork is amazing
like Shaq just for his size that size
have feet like that it's crazy
it's hard yeah I'm just but anyway I
would watch it I would but yeah we'd
love to see UFC versus boxing because I
think that we naturally have this like
curiosity about who are the most
destructive people and boxing has this
Legacy right and a huge Advantage within
their own discipline when the MMA guys
come in and they fight the boxers they
often lose